You would not be able to walk after that, there's no chance.
We're watching the daredevil, this scene is great because-
Thank you to today's sponsor ExpressVPN for bringing you this episode to stay tuned at the end to learn how to get three months free.
What's up, guys? Hey, welcome back to another episode of stuntman react. We are joined by Eric Linden master stunt coordinator stunt extraordinaire.
He's got the flips, he's got the kicks!
Welcome, welcome back.
Eric's gonna give us a bunch of great insight. Some really cool scenes from movies, some things you may not have known we're gonna be
We're going to be educated today.
*Laughter*
Aight let's get to it!
*gun shots*
*man falling screams*
Oh frick yeah- heck yeah.
beep
Oh man- dang
That's awesome!
By the way
When the buildings explode there's literally dummies on stands in front and you can see them very clearly.
You can see the stand on the back of the guy!
I miss old school pyrotechnics like this. I want to be a pyrotechnic actually is my first thing when I came to movies-
Oh, really? -Yeah bigger power technician was like my main drive. I got close enough.
I definitely watched this,
like on VHS back when I was younger watching it now like they actually doing like some really good stunt work.
Those dudes diving out of that car, like literally there's they're like, okay, so you're gonna ride in this car?
We're gonna do a small pipe ramp and just bail when you get, when you feel when it's right!
Yeah, try not to die!
There's another trend that like luckily is like just gone away is people just kind of like doing the like-
They get hit like yeah. How dedicated,
is your paramilitary force to still fight back against what manganese murdered half your school? Oh, yeah, each one of them's like, I'm the guy.
This guy does the most graceful twist. They're like, "ah, we need a gymnast to take a grenade hit."
That, there's an air ram! Oh, there they are!
Wow, they're blatantly in the frame.
An air ram, like almost like a reverse
bear trap where this- this thing is- is it's closed like this and when the guy steps on it,
it hits a switch and a pneumatic opens like that.
He gets catapulted through the air. And you've done air ram hits before right? Oh, yeah.
Do you ever worry about like your legs buckling out from under you? A hundred percent! If you hit it
and you're kind of not like locked out like not with your knee locked out, but your quad completely flexed,
it will just buckle your leg and I- I mean there's been cases where people have
Their legs have buckled right? And they've gone up in the air. So then they would land back on it and fire off.
It's almost like a dinosaur thing that they don't really do anymore because they weren't really wiping wires
in this. Now when we would, you know, a guy goes flying down the hill or
Batman throws him across thing. You're- you're gonna use wire work to get them there and you can wipe the wire so easily now,
it's almost not worth it. You're gonna end up erasing the air ram later anyway, so yeah.
Now air rams might be dinosaur technology, but I love me some dinosaurs special effects.
So, you guys may have seen me get little on fire by Erik Lyndon.
You guys want to see me launch off of an air ram through the air maybe off of a cliff, please,
Leave a comment down in the comment section.
Let's get back to the video.
I really love that type of like- like the squibs and stuff like that
that's just like the film-making that- that was the way they always used to do it.
Like I- I'm not like a big fan of like CG unless it's used very subtly.
I mean, I think when it comes to like showcasing
danger and like human talent, when you get computers involved in that
we were trying to actually show the feat of grace or strength or bravery.
Adding CG to that takes away from that aspect of it because there's still a bit of reality in films.
You know when somebody's going to do a crazy motorcycle jump or a triple flip crash into like a wall,
you still I think it's important to like recognize the reality of
having a human really go out there and put themselves on the line to do that shot and CG can really take away from that.
This scene is great!
This is really what these people kind of went through you would have a duel.
You know, you kind of assume like there's some you know, click-clack and somebody gets stabbed and they die.
However often times you wouldn't die,
you would just kind of get picked apart and start to bleed to death.
Which makes your energy wear down you're dealing with pain and if you get hit in the wrong spot like you may not be able
to use your arm or use it properly, you know, he's been struck and his sword arm
so he uses his other arm to like hold up that arm.
It's just like a small detail that that they did a really great job with.
When you like look at something like the Phantom Menace, you know,
you can pick apart parts where they're just completely not aiming at each other's vital parts.
They're not aiming for their head and they're kind of making blocks out in the middle of nowhere, right? I'm a thrust
way over here off to the side because I want
your sword to come to block it so that I can then turn come around and cut at your throat.
See how Liam hits the sword? Yeah- Because you can hit the flat part of it without cutting your hand.
It's real quick!
But that's kind of some of this stuff like as a fight coordinator when you can find those little things,
it just isn't what everybody else is gonna do.
Yeah, it's not the most flashy thing in the world,
but as far as like really feeling and those beats in between they kind of like build the tension and
the hero you've been watching the whole time is like clearly losing and ultimately I mean he loses.
But that arrogance got the better of him.
Oh
That's what you get for being pompous!
So think this does a great job is just showing a real sword fight like just how brutal it truly was.
So we actually look at the stats for these videos and like,
60% of the viewers who watch these videos aren't subscribed to the channel. They're not subscribed?
Yeah, there's like 60% of the people that watch aren't subscribed!
I'll find you and subscribe you myself!
I will find you and I will subscribe you.
We're watching the daredevil, this scene in particular
I think it's like, perfect and also my good buddies are the ones that did it. So like it's,
fantastic.
He goes into the door, that's Charlie
The actor door closes stunt double comes out stunt double is Chris Brewster
It's a fantastic way of using the Texas switch
Actor goes behind a barrel out of door without cutting the stunt double comes out
Stunt double then does whatever it is that he needs to do
Goes behind a pole or some sort of obstacle and the actor has now moved into the correct position. He gets up continues on
Another thing I think they did really good job of and daredevil as a whole is he'll do spinny flippy type of things
But that's inherently the character of daredevil that was portrayed in the comics and everything and the stunt coordinator did an amazing job
Doing these flips in like a manner that made sense. It wasn't like gratuitous. It seemed to work within the flow of the choreography
Hello Bella comes off the wall there. Yes. He's exhausted
Yeah
I think they do a great job of kind of like some of the stuff that they did in Rob Roy
The hero is getting tired, you know
He's not superhuman per se
Although he is like a highly trained guy, you know
He's taken some hits you can see that he's not always making the perfect move and sometimes he pays for it
And I love it when you see a little bit of vulnerability from the hero's
Stunt double goes back into the door and and then of course the actor comes back out and finishes the scene
People always wonder if that hallway scene that we just saw is a true one. ER and the answer is yes
I think they did it 12 times and they ended up using I think that tenth or eleventh one
So this one is another famous daredevil one, er they use
camera wipes
To create this water. So it is not a true one. Er
But they were able to kind of up the ante there real slick cuz they were doing wipes not where you could barely even tell
Cg chain, yeah
Little wirework there this yeah, the stairs are all padded. They put into light on every single staircase
Charlie who plays daredevil is a
Fantastic fighter. He did a ton of his own fighting. He's amazing
I fought him on the rooftop, you know
He kind of like gives me a push. Kick and I'm like dude. Just give it to me
This dude hits so hard the next day. I woke up and literally had a footprint bruise on
my chest
He's a great actor and a phenomenal fighter
So this is one of our most
Commented on movies to talk about please leave a comment below if there's something you would love to see us react to to talk about
We love reading them. It's great inspiration. So please do not hold back. Alright
I'm a big fan of like the the little pauses where they're letting tension build
They're sizing each other up or stuff like when qui-gon sits and meditates while Maul wants to just tear them apart
Looks like good pacing good contrast, you know. Yeah, it's great
I'm just waiting for somebody to grab like a hot pan and like throat dude
Did you would not be able to walk
Does it make you wonder why I didn't didn't do that to begin
Yeah, did he feel like he was losing and he decided to pull that out though Thanks
Or was he just sick of it? Like I've gone through two windows and a couple wine bottles. Yeah. Yeah
So in the part where he traps his leg I noticed they're using the dropped frame technique
Which is a great way to add some punch to your shots when you're doing action movies
He watch the movement of his feet here every frame things kind of move
The same distance like a spoke move from here to here then here to here then here to here. It's an equal movement
Boom, you'll notice that his foot jumps twice the distance that's been moving every other frame
You can just cut out that one frame of acceleration and it just makes an impact sail so much harder
And I mean, I think that's eco just just literally I think they just Pat up a little bit and they go for it
I think these guys are clearly like true savages
How long do you think it took you for them to film that
Probably a week no week. At least I'd be really fast
I feel like if you're only doing the fighting and you've already previz everything because I believe that that director
does something very specific where he sheets for the edit like he kind of knows like I need this much for this shot and I
Think it's because they think previz it a lot so that then they shoot just what they need, you know
just like that bottle thing where you goes boom and blocks the bottle if you already know where you're going and you know if that
works
You know you you're just using that one bead of it
So they could have very well shot that once and been done
Another thing that stands out to me about this action scene that really says how well-designed it is is that they are against a bright
White background and there's silhouettes are easy to read now
There's a trend in Hollywood movies to have guys in black fighting guys in black against dark black backgrounds
And you can't really follow the action whereas in this scene. It's way more easy to follow
Hey guys, welcome back to brand guy reacts too bad and great brands. I've got Nico here with me. I've got Clint guys
Thanks for being here today. Let's just jump into it. See we got today
Expressvpn is a premium Virtual Private Network service. Oh, man expressvpn
Dude, I love these guys. Not only have they been a huge sponsor of the show for a really long time
But they're also sponsored today's episode. I mean, oh stop right there, as you know, they have like first-class internet privacy protection
Yeah. Oh, yeah, I definitely recognize that
Yeah
now guys
As you know without a VPN all of your internet browsing data can be tracked by
ISPs cell phone providers companies and guess what hackers?
So huge props to expressvpn for protecting people out. There was that as they do their daily searches?
Did you did you have anything you wanted to say about this, Nico?
The IP address you use is one of the thousands. Yeah. Can you go frame-by-frame? This is one of my favorite parts
So you see what they did is is they made expressvpn available in over 94 countries
which means no matter where you are in the world you basically get the fastest speeds out of any VPN service provider and
They also gave you 24/7 customer service you can get help whenever you need it
Oh and they made browser extensions available for things like Chrome and Safari
So it's super easy to use when you're just browsing around them on the net
You can get a subscription for less than seven bucks a month with a 30-day money-back guarantee
All you have to do is go to expressvpn comm slash corridor crew niko. Come on, man. You know how to spell it
It's right there on the monitor
you just go to
Exp re SS VPN comm slash corridor crew and you can get three months free when you sign up for a year
But anyway, that's that's about the end of the episode
So if you guys want to see us react to any other branch, just let us know in the comments below. We'll be going through
Everyone thank you for watching if you happen to be active on reddit, we actually have a corridor a subreddit our slash corridor
There'll be a link down in the description
It's a great way to get in touch with us leave requests of course can leave a comment in this video
But just another avenue to communicate with us
also
If you're interested in getting a distance
Eric actually has like a frequently asked questions thing that he's put together that answers a lot of those questions
It's a really good info
But otherwise if you just have really cool scenes you want to talk about or just want to tell him good job?
He's a badass you can go and follow him at Eric Linden. Awesome. Thanks a lot for having me guys. Love doing this appreciate